they're all Marines or one of the
world's elite fighting forces the
training regime is grueling so they need
all the energy they can get from the
food they eat these recruits are being
pushed to their absolute physical and
mental limits I'm dying to find out what
fuel actually keeps them going look at
them they look absolutely hard as nails
I'm meeting corporals Ben Slater and Tim
Richards who served in Iraq and
Afghanistan and are currently down in
Devon to train up the new recruits good
to see you both these recruits train
like maniacs and eat like horses but the
food they're given is bland and boring
it's the qualities of food it's
important of crews here for 32 weeks and
they're going to the same meals day in
day out it gets quite mundane I'm here
to show them that simple healthy food
with all the nutrition that they need
can be tasty too but first they're going
to teach me a lesson
slowly nervous hands down
get on with it I'm going to join 20
recruits on the rugged terrain of
Woodbury Common for today's exercise the
endurance course so timewise I'll also
take two asleep
well if we can get off the time schools
itself either 25 minutes yeah little bit
low fatty the only problem is I'm
running late as PTI corporal Reggie red
drop lets me know right ramsey UAB
press-ups you late sorry how many please
hundred Tony [ __ ] late now all the
way down
he's always that miss one of the first
in the morning to do a small [ __ ] me
some bye
three two one go a lady twice as old as
the young recruit but there's no way
I'll let that affect my performance
right let's have a good time here though
drums a young recruits ops you find it
hard they even find especially hard
they'll be times there where you will
not want to carry on this course is all
about endurance you run in teams of
three and each man has to carry a sa80
assault rifle and equipment weighing in
at 32 pounds within minutes I was
feeling the pain
gasping for breath we reached the
sheepdip here's where that famous means
teamwork kicks in change around after a
lungful of air I get to return the favor
Selena
a raw marine recruits daily intake is
over 4,000 calories a day nearly twice
that of an average male I'm beginning to
understand why they need quite so much
fuel for you
arthelene occurred we reached the smarty
tubes and my heart sinks when I realize
which one they're sending me through
okay moving on [ __ ] sake give MZ move
your ass hi stick yawn without the beads
all that think let them speak our
motivations go what's the only weapon
bros you get a move on clay gonna kill
it going man
hello
[ __ ] up head up tried on 34 minutes and
three seconds Ramsey that is shocking
what they eat if you let loose I've not
broken any records but at least I didn't
come last it has to be the hardest
course I'll be on Form Athens the dorm
Athens you name it
how's the longest 30 miles my entire
[ __ ] life yeah guys are amazing I
mean that's what you call fit fit back
to base to get into warm dry clothes
then it's time for me to teach them a
lesson
in cooking these guys aren't feeling the
body with the right food they've got no
chance of getting through a day's
training let alone 32 [ __ ] weeks what
are you eating in the field we have 10
my Russian pack breakfast sausage and
beans sausage and beans
nice stuff up me look at that slight
inside a [ __ ] nappy holy crap
swell Prince Harry was complaining about
it recently on service in Afghanistan
yep tell me it's a far cry coming out of
Buckingham Palace yeah you guys deserve
better right we're gonna do something
exciting
yeah spicy beef curry after putting me
to the test it's now my turn to give the
orders for this substantial dish we're
gonna use rum steak which is high in
protein
cut it in half and we're gonna do now is
get these really nice large cubes have
you ever been out looked at the rations
I'm just the fact that I'm waiting that
yes quite cozy gloves will take out the
real stuff herbs spices Tabasco anything
to take the taste off what your you
marinate the beef and garam masala
yogurt olive oil and salt and pepper now
we go chop the onion whole lot the whole
lot great fresh garlic and ginger over
the onions I can think of the
indigestion eaten all those [ __ ]
rations so gingers the welcome spice add
chilies sugar to help camera onions
followed by coriander cardamom and
ground spice dry roasting will help
intensify the flavor mix fennel
coriander cumin and fenugreek seeds
which are rich in dietary fiber and
soothe the stomach
quickly color the marinated beef to seal
in the flavors that's the noise order
here
mixing the beef adding chopped tomatoes
and tomato puree the tomato paste goes
in in place of any sort of cream or
butter such a nice healthy way of eating
a spicy curry stock in a normal B stock
the spicy beef curry is then left to
simmer before being served with rice
a virtually fat and cholesterol free
slow-release energy source gentlemen
come on guys places day is it now go put
a spice in yours
yeah those [ __ ] press ups are smaller
bits bits you're spitting it already out
yeah yeah she's gonna these guys are
half my age right yeah I didn't come
last
that's the most important are you happy
yeah yeah me I really like that the only
Tarzan next time oh yeah I'm gonna give
you a [ __ ] run
come on granddad sister it's [ __ ]
freezing
and this here all his organs with the
innards out we hang the Hogs carcass
from a tree to skin it